hello everyone this is Sal here and I'm
here with Jeffrey Rosen who's head of
the National Constitution Center what
are we going to talk about today Jeff
we're gonna talk about the preamble to
the US Constitution that sounds very
important
it is very important the entire theory
of popular sovereignty is contained
within these beautiful words so we've
got a lot to talk about and before we
even get into it what do you mean by the
theory of popular sovereignty
so the preamble begins with the famous
words we the people of the United States
and those signal that in the United
States power belongs to We the People it
doesn't belong to our representatives in
Congress it doesn't even belong to the
state governments and that was a huge
shift because an original draft of the
preamble read we the people of the
states of New Hampshire Massachusetts
Rhode Island Connecticut and so forth
but James Wilson who is the main drafter
of the preamble changed those words and
at some point the preamble was changed
to the famous words we know now we the
people of the United States that meant
that when some southern states tried to
secede from the union before the Civil
War arguing that they were sovereign as
state governments President Lincoln
resisted their constitutional ability to
secede saying that since we the people
of the United States had created the
Constitution a majority of we the people
of the United States would have to agree
before any state could leave it so
that's why it was a huge shift in a
conception of power that James Wilson
embodied in these words before the
preamble people believed that
legislators were sovereign and Britain
the king in Parliament was sovereign but
in America thanks to Wilson and his
brilliant colleagues we the people of
the United States as a whole became
sovereign and that came to chart the
entire course of constitutional history
but then we have all of these purposes
for which the Constitution was formed
and to form a more perfect union
establish justice domestic tranquility
common defense general welfare and
secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves and our posterity and then
we're saying that we that's the reason
that we established the Constitution
there's lots done back there but maybe
we should focus on those final words
secure the blessings of liberty to
selves on our posterity the framers
believe that our rights come not from
government but from God or nature that
were born with them and when we moved
from the state of nature into civil
society to form a government
we surrender temporary control over
certain of those rights in order to
secure the safety and security of the
rights we've retained so that means that
certain rights are unalienable to use
Jefferson's language in the declaration
we can't alienate them to government
only form government and the purpose of
alienating temporary control over
certain rights like allowing the
government to punish murder rather than
you know having private violence is to
secure the blessings of liberty of the
retain natural rights the first of which
the framers believed was complete
freedom of conscience the right to
believe or not to believe according to
the dictates of our conscience so we
really see that that idea of securing
the blessings of liberty is implicit in
the idea that our rights come from God
and not government that government only
has temporary control of them and
reinforces once again that we should
never confuse the actions of the
government laws that Congress of the
state governments passed with the will
of the people we the people are
sovereign the government is our servants
we are the principles and when there's a
clash between the will of the principles
represented by the Constitution and the
will of the servants represented by the
legislators you prefer the principle to
the agent that was what Hamilton said in
Federalist 78 in justifying the Supreme
Court's power to strike down
unconstitutional laws that because the
Constitution ratified in the name of We
the People represents our views more
profoundly than those of ordinary laws
that's why judges have to prefer the
Constitution to ordinary laws so once
again we're seeing packed into this
preamble so much natural law theory and
theory of popular sovereignty there's
one other really important notion
contained in those words securing the
blessings of liberty in the name of We
the People and that's that the
Constitution itself didn't get to speak
for We the People when it was proposed
it wasn't until it was ratified by
special conventions that had been
elected for that purpose that it earned
the right to speak in the name of We the
People as a whole James Wilson was very
keen on the idea that was the ratifying
convention it's not the Constitutional
Convention
Philadelphia that gave the document its
status as supreme law and that idea that
only laws that go through a special
procedure specified in the Constitution
in article 5 which is the amendment
procedure or by special constitutional
conventions get to speak in the name of
We the People is absolutely core to the
whole theory of American
constitutionalism why were the founding
fathers so focused on this innate notion
of popular sovereignty of elected
officials being servant to the people
and and making it so strongly embedded
even here in the preamble they just
fought a revolution based on the idea
that the tyrannical King George had
infringed the natural rights of the
people had refused to grant basic powers
of representation and had broken the
social contract and therefore had lost
the right to govern people because he
was governing without consent one of the
natural rights that people believed were
unalienable and retained by the people
was the right to alter and abolish
government whenever it threatens the
retained natural rights of the people
that's in the Declaration of
Independence and in the Constitution it
can be found in Article five so that
right of revolution was part and parcel
of the idea that our basic natural
rights are retained and you have to
remember how revolutionary it was to be
talking of popular sovereignty in 1787
there were almost no democratic
self-government sonner 'the then there
have been small-scale democracies in
Greek Greece and Rome in Athens Solon or
in Sparta life surges had been lawgivers
but no people had ever as the scholar
Akhil amar says voted on a written
constitution before deliberated it and
had it ratified in their name so that's
what was so radical about that even the
handful of minor of the sort of partial
democracies at the time like the limited
suffrage in the British Parliament or
the Swiss cantons hadn't had a written
constitution that was ratified by
popular deliberation so that's what made
it radical and that was that was
Wilson's distinct contribution to
America as an entire theory of
democratic self-government and that's
why if you had to talk about the
essence of constitutionalism today it's
not populism it's not a quick direct
vote it's not brexit it's not a
referendum it's long periods of
deliberation so that the text earns the
right to speak in the name of We the
People and it was the very reason for
which the revolutionaries fought the
American Revolution fascinating and
let's continue so we said we have We the
People the United States it establishes
the popular sovereignty and then it says
in order to and it lists a bunch of
reasons why we are what we're trying to
do and we already did secure the
blessings of liberty to ourselves and
our posterity what are the other things
we want to talk about let's go back an
order and the next the first purpose is
in order to form a more perfect union
well that was the central goal of the
Constitutional Convention the previous
union represented by the Articles of
Confederation had been imperfect that
was sovereign states that were unable to
achieve common purposes they couldn't
raise money to support forces in war
they couldn't put down rebellions by
debtors in Massachusetts known as Shay's
rebellion they needed a unanimous vote
to achieve anything and essentially the
government didn't work so the framers
came to Philadelphia in order to form a
more perfect union by establishing a
constitution strong enough to achieve
common purposes but restrained enough to
protect retain natural rights and that's
what a perfect union is it's not a
consolidated government because the
state's retained powers under the 10th
amendment all powers not bested in the
United States as a whole or retained by
the states or the people and ultimately
it's we the people who retain the
ultimate power because we're the ones
who are sovereign but we can parcel that
power out either to state governments or
to the federal government in order to
ensure the protections of Liberty so
that's what a more perfect union is and
that's why it was so appropriate that
Lincoln in defending the Union during
the Civil War resisted the authority of
the state governments to secede on the
grounds that we the people of the United
States needed to consent before the
Union could become less perfect I just
want to double click on that a little
bit because the words more and perfect
nor normally go together you're they're
perfect or you're not and so
part of the narrative that I think I'm
hearing is that we had the Articles of
Confederation which were imperfect and
we want to get closer to being perfect
and so that's one of the reasons here
many times when I look at to form a more
perfect union it also at least to me
kind of invokes this notion of
continuously trying to get better even
from the starting point
you're right to parse it closely we're
trying continuously to get better but
perfection doesn't mean amalgamation in
other words the most perfect union
wouldn't be a total union in which all
power is united in the federal
government for example and not partial
DAP between the federal government and
the states and also not separated out so
the various branches can check each
other we want a union perfect enough to
achieve common purposes but not so
strong as to threaten Liberty and it was
that delicate balance that was crucial
to Madison's vision and that led to most
of the tensions in the Constitutional
Convention and then established justice
well my goodness that's there's a lot
packed into that and you might think
that that mandate to establish justice
gives judges the power to do justice
regardless of you know let the heavens
fall to use the expression but that's
not what the Supreme Court has held in a
really interesting case the Supreme
Court it was called Jacobson versus
Massachusetts that came down in 1905 the
Supreme Court rejected the claim that
the preamble to the Constitution
conferred independent powers that could
be enforced by judges in other words it
wasn't a general mandate that allow
judges to do justice regardless instead
justice Harlan said in the Jacobsen case
although the preamble indicates the
general purposes for which the people
ordained and established the
Constitution it has never been regarded
as the source of any substantive power
conferred on the government of the
United States or any of its departments
such powers embrace only those expressly
granted in the body of the Constitution
or and there's the final bit and such as
may be implied from those so granted so
established justice is a broad
declaration of purposes many
parts of the Constitution helped the
government to establish justice
including the Bill of Rights which
requires that people can't be deprived
of Liberty without due process of law if
they're gonna have a criminal trial they
have all sorts of rights to confront
witnesses to be tried by jury and so
forth but it's those specific
articulation of the rights that allow us
to establish justice that are the ones
that judges can enforce the goal the
broad goal is the one set out in a
preamble and then we have ensure
domestic tranquility provide for the
common defense promote the general
welfare yeah so domestic tranquility is
with some of of central concern to the
framers they're concerned about armed
mobs like those I mentioned in
Massachusetts and Shay's rebellion where
a debtor's and farmers in western
Massachusetts are rebelling against
their creditors so they want to allow
the government enough power to put down
these interactions but they don't want a
government so strong that it will create
standing armies that can be permanent
threats to Liberty of the kind that King
George's army was so that's why the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
wants to provide for well-regulated
militias that can help ensure domestic
tranquility but doesn't want to empower
a permanent standing army because it
believes that ultimately the people do
have to retain the ability to take up
arms to defend their own Liberty if the
government is threatening it as part of
their unalienable right to alter and
abolish government so that's the
domestic tranquility part and then the
common defense of course is hugely
important and Congress has the power to
declare war the president is
commander-in-chief the president has the
power to repeal sudden attacks but
otherwise it's supposed to be Congress
in theory at least that authorizes the
deployment of troops abroad and the
parts of Article one for Congress and
Article two for the president that give
those two branches war-making powers
help to ensure that the Constitution
provides for the common defense the
final clause I hesitated to introduce
because it's so incredibly broad promote
the general welfare Wow
well I mean that could be read as a kind
of blank check for the government to do
whatever it thinks is necessary to
promote the general welfare but both the
supreme court and also the
ratifying the Constitution made clear
that the general welfare clause was not
a blank check it was Congress and the
president could only exercise the powers
that were either explicitly granted by
the Constitution or could be fairly
implied by them and yet at the same time
Chief Justice John Marshall and others
suggested that those powers have to be
broadly construed enough to achieve the
purposes of the Constitution which
include promoting the general welfare so
you might say that promoting the general
welfare is a different expression of the
goal of promoting a more perfect union
except you could say that there's
separate goal of passing laws that are
in the general welfare again without
threatening liberty and that Clause once
again in bodies this tectonic balance
between empowering government but also
protecting retained rights so just to
make sure that we got all of the big
points we've learned that although the
preamble itself isn't a basis for
justice like the body of the
Constitution it establishes that we the
people are the source of political power
in the United States it explains that
the Constitution would form a more
perfect union between the states and the
federal government than the weak
Articles of Confederation while ensuring
that the people still retain their
natural rights to learn more about the
preamble which I encourage you to do
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics